welcome everybody to the this eth
session in the world of speculative
fiction series um what we do here is
examine the narrative worlds and
philosophical themes and great authors
from Science Fiction and Fantasy
uh this time around i' I've been the
person who picked them all out if we
continue this for another year quite a
few of you have given me ideas about who
we should tackle next so we'll talk with
the library uh since it's you know the
eighth one we can start you know having
that conversation soon this session is
devoted to Ursula Ken um I just I only
have one one of her books along here uh
but um you know there's quite a few and
she she's a very prolific author in a
number of different fields uh she's also
a living author the first one I think
that we've actually talked about so far
there's going to be a few others that
are still producing uh one of whom
better still keep producing and that's
we we're finishing up with George
Martin so hopefully he'll stay alive for
a long time um but yeah I think most of
the other ones everyone we've done so
far is deceased um hopefully she'll you
know stay alive for for quite a while
longer so uh I'm Greg Sandler I'm a
philosopher who transitioned from
traditional Academia into doing more
public work like like this and I'm also
a big sci-fi and fantasy fan so this is
my guilty pleasure reading that I get to
go back to um books that I'd read in my
adolescence and my early 20s and really
loved and uh I can justify it to myself
as part of my work since I'm talking
about philosophical themes so what we'll
do is the normal format I've got a few
sort of introductory Reflections and
remarks um I've given you a handout on
her
bibliography or biography a little bit
of her
bibliography um both of which are are
rather selective she's done so much that
it's hard to put it on one page then
we'll talk about the narrative world of
certain of her novels and stories called
the hinish cycle or stories um I'd say
it's probably about like maybe a quarter
of she wrote fits into that and then
I've got some philosophical themes
picked out um we'll talk about the you
know this this league or the Acumen and
what what that signifies for her we'll
talk about her own um I guess you could
call it commitment to dosm and anarchism
and her interpretation of that we'll
talk about the importance of the
particular and the concrete for her and
then um the essence of humanity and uh
gender relations which comes up a lot
lot in this work right here the the left
hand of darkness and I've got sort of a
a bonus theme that's not connected with
the the hinish stuff so this will be if
we have like some some extra time at the
end if there's sufficient interest in it
um there's a story that she wrote that
some of you might have encountered in in
in philosophy classes or sometimes in
literature classes called those who walk
away from
omals it's probably the most
anthologized and taught story she wrote
um and it's it's got some cool themes to
it so we can talk about that it doesn't
actually fit into the scope of this so I
wanted to put that at the end um as
usual we'll have some time for Q&A at
the end but you can always you know
raise a question or if you got comments
at any time uh you you guys know by now
I'm pretty good at getting back on the
track um in part because I've got my
notes in front of me so that that helps
I don't know how good I'd be at it
without notes um but yeah as questions
anytime and we'll certainly go into
discussion about that so the initial
remarks and Reflections um like zelasney
who we looked at last time uh Ursula Kay
green is somebody who fits into What's
called the new wave of Science Fiction
and some of the other authors we're
going to look at in the coming months
fit into that as well Michael morock who
we're looking at next month he fits into
that I guess you could say Philip K dick
although he's kind of one-of a kind
himself but he he I guess he fits into
that as well um he's coming up in in
October and a lot of what that involved
was a turn away from hard science
fiction just focused on
technology and a lot of Space Opera sort
of stuff um to more um the soft Sciences
or or as we call them the human Sciences
um sociology psychology anthropology
looking at characters
and trying to flush them out into real
human beings ecology is another thing
with Frank Herbert also with Ursula Ken
and so uh they're part of that and then
there's also the aspect of writing for
the sake of doing good writing some of
the hard science fiction authors you
know they they wrote well um but they
they weren't that focused on metaphor or
you know you might call it the artistic
part of of Storytelling um some of them
did a really great job at it like like a
van Voit almost um you know that was
part of how he he did things or aimof
they were very good at that but in a lot
of ways they're not as writers up to the
par of zelas or Len as far as the
imagery and the metaphor and all the
development of character that goes into
their their work so that's that's part
of the the new wave um she actually
prefers the term imaginative fiction
rather than science fiction which I can
understand why
um she thinks that science fiction is a
little bit too restrictive because it
has all these overtones of you know the
robots and lasers all that sort of Space
Opera kind of stuff um she's a very very
highly regarded author uh within you
know Science Fiction and Fantasy circles
she's influenced a lot of people she's
won a lot of awards she's still
productive at the present time she uh
has has she's she's embraced the the
internet and although she didn't Embrace
Google we'll talk about that a little
bit in in a moment um and she uh you
know you can go online and you just type
her in you'll find her website um
occasionally she writes essays for Young
Writers about how to how to write well
so she's very engaged um I also would
like to say that um She's Got an essay
that I brought up early on in this
series called from elfland to pipy and
she's talking about the the act of um
creating she's calling it imagin fiction
or or she uses the word fantasy in there
as well and she talks about tolken quite
a lot in in that um it's kind of
springboarding off of token's own um on
fairy stories so it's a great little
essay um which originally she she
releases a chatbook um so it's very
small about um the work that she she's
doing so all that said um this time as I
thought about what I wanted to say at
the start I decided I wanted to indulge
myself a bit more than I usually do in a
little bit of personal reminiscence and
appreciation of Ursula Kaya green the
first work of hers that I ever
encountered was when I was in Middle
School and now that I I did the research
I realized it wasn't a it was a very
recent work of hers it had only been out
for a couple years and it was called the
beginning place um I read it as a
seventh grader uh at a time that was was
you know rather tough for me my my dad
had died um earlier that that year uh
that summer I was living out in the the
country uh at that time it was
Countryside now it's pretty pretty welld
developed on the border of Wales and
Delafield you know further west from
here and um you know I was going through
adolescence I was going to a private
school where I did not fit in at all you
know and so I was going through the sort
of I think typical um adolescent stuff
with a couple other things thrown in and
that book really hit me fortunately I
did find it in the library at that that
school and it was it was a great work
it's a Coming of Age story about these
two kids who were older than me at the
time Irene and Hugh and they're both
coming from screwed up families out in
the suburbs but there's a Woods nearby
and they go into this Woods she's been
doing this for a while he finally does
this and it's called the beginning place
because um it's a place for new
beginnings and it takes them to another
world I don't remember the name of it
starts with the tea it's very long um
but there's there you know there's like
a whole story there with um you know the
town being beset by fear and it turns
out that it's a it's personified as a
dragon he has to kill the dragon there's
a lot of conflicts between them but
eventually by the end they have to work
together it's almost like a you know a
plot for for a movie in many ways and by
the end um they' they've managed to fall
in love and and things were written you
know in a way that as an adolescent I
could really appreciate because the the
the love scenes are not the sort of uh
verbal equivalent of the the Vaseline on
the lens soft focus on everybody you
remember back in the 80s how people
would kiss and then everything would
turn into like a soft blur um it wasn't
like that it was very serious uh and
there was a sense of uh kind of
melancholy to the entire story a sense
of vulnerability on the characters part
I I hadn't read anything much like that
before I'd read a lot of fantasy and a
lot of Science Fiction but I I hadn't
seen anything like that so so it began
you know resonating with me and then I
read the Earth sea Trilogy that I think
probably a lot of you have read um those
are written for for children uh but
adults I think can appreciate them as
well and they're they're really quite
good and and that same sort of sense of
of melancholy and vulnerability runs
through those works so the main
character get is a little bit different
than the heroic figures in in other
stories and it's that's a Coming of Age
story at least at the start as well
about this guy who turns out to have a
talent for magic um gets himself into
all sorts of Adventures he's kind of an
outsider figure um goes to the magic
school so imagine you know it's sort of
like prefiguring Harry Potter in some
ways except a lot I I don't want to say
darker but there's less people involved
it's on an island rather than being you
know in a special wizard PL land and uh
the people aren't very nice to each
other most of the time um he manages to
open up a rift between dimensions and a
shadow comes through who haunts him and
it's only by the end that he's able to
overcome this after it's done a lot of
damage to to other people um and so then
after that I started reading her other
stories and I I really enjoyed them this
I I read in high school along with um
several other of her her works in the
highest cycle and some of the other ones
like lathe of Heaven um really beautiful
and uh kind of good dystopian literature
story and I lik them so much that I even
I passed these down to my little cousin
at that time little now he's a grown man
who's who's quite big uh Christopher um
who was starting to appreciate science
fiction I lik them so much I thought I
had to share them with with with other
people so
um yeah that's you know I I really uh
when I when I had the chance to get her
into the list she was she was one of the
first people that I I wanted to have in
there and um going back to it and
rereading this this stuff as uh you know
person in my 40s now um the stories have
just gotten better they they they
haven't lost anything with age the way
some science fiction stuff has I think
these are going to be timeless
classics so that's enough of of that uh
let's talk about her biography and her
her Works um you notice that she's you
know she's in her late ' 80s now um
she's born in Berkeley California to an
anthropologist and an author so it's
already kind of an
unusual uh childhood starts writing
pretty early um she decides that she
wants to to write she's not actually
placing anything in in magazines uh
until much later as you'll see and um
this is skipping ahead a little bit but
she starts writing
novels uh while she's in in college um
none of the stuff that she actually
writes as novels gets any traction At
first she sends it out to Publishers and
they're like nah this isn't this really
isn't our our sort of stuff and it takes
a while for her to to catch on um she
did say some interesting things about
growing up in the family that she did
that that affect the way that she writes
in in one interview she says uh it was
something in the a my father breathed as
an anthropologist the people he knew the
people who came to the house and the
things they talked about you could say I
grew up in a house where all the doors
were open there weren't just a lot of
shut doors and no locked doors and that
does something to a kid's mind it gives
them a freedom and a kind of security in
the world okay people are different
there are all kinds of different people
isn't that interesting instead of G
isn't that horrible so she uh she talked
quite a bit about this her father as an
anthropologist would would would have
some of his um I suppose she used the
word informance meaning the people that
he got his information from uh but I I
suppose we call them clients today um he
would have them come to the house and
they would talk about things and there
were a lot of intellectual discussions
going on so it was very fruitful for
somebody like her she goes to college
starts writing novels already in college
and poetry she wrote a lot of poetry and
then she goes to graduate school and
then um she she goes on a full bright to
Paris where she's going to meet her her
husband um and uh uh Charles lwin
eventually they they are going to settle
in Portland and she'll give up working
on her her PhD they they don't actually
go all the way with that and then she
has a a number of children she actually
had had a great quote that I was sharing
with Andy earlier today as I was doing
some of this research
she she says um and I'm paraphrasing
here they she was asked about you know
well how how did you write while you had
children to to raise she said well you
know I did it from 10: to 12 at night
but the other thing that was important
is she said a person can't do two
full-time jobs so if she was expected to
do full-time mothering and full-time
writing it would never would have worked
um but she had a husband who shared the
work with her and she said two people if
they manage things right can do three
full-time jobs but you can't just have
one person picking up the the entire
slack so that was something uh quite
quite uh important another thing I
should have mentioned too uh so I
skipped over uh right into college she
went to a high school with Philip K
dick and uh she only found this out
later on uh and it makes sense why she
didn't know she said Berkeley High had
35 500 kids so you didn't know all all
the people in your high school and
apparently Philip K dick nobody knew who
he was at that time um he he stuck to
himself he he didn't didn't stick his
neck out she called him the invisible
classmate at one time now later on
they'll have a correspondence and she'll
actually take him to task for how he um
presents female characters uh and uh
Philip K dick will change his mind and
try to write better female characters at
at one point um
you notice like looking down the the
list I I only have a few of the awards
that she won on there she had two novels
that both won uh the Hugo and the nebula
award that's you know at that time I
don't know if anybody else has done that
since but she's the only person up until
that time who'd ever done that two
awards from two different you know
perspectives on on the same novel you
notice um she's very productive these
are these are just her her actual uh
collections of short stories or novels I
didn't put you know other like
Standalone short stories most of the
works of poetry aren't in there um these
are all the things that that she wrote
in terms of her science fiction and
fantasy novels and the ones that are in
in dark uh black those are the ones that
fit into this hinish cycle so you can
see when she's creating things
um she she also talks and this is
something I think is kind of interesting
in her
biography um she talked about how the
Advent of of feminism being taken
serious it's not like feminism just came
about in the 60s right because we have
Mary walstone craft long before that um
but it became part of the culture in the
60s and she she wrote this or actually
she said this in an interview um then
came literary feminism which was a
tremendous problem and gift to me I had
to handle it and I wasn't sure I could
because I'm not much good on Theory go
away just let me write and the fact is I
was getting stuck in my writing I
couldn't keep pretending I was a man and
so feminism came along at just the right
moment for me it said to me hey guess
what you're a woman you can write like a
woman I saw that women don't have to
write about what men write about or
write what men think they want to read I
saw that women have whole areas of
experience men don't have and that
they're worth writing and reading about
and then she said then I went back
really read Virginia wolf she she'd read
Virginia wolf earlier so that's somebody
who she she looks at as a sort of
progenitor for herself and she said I
read all the books the feminists were
offering to us books that other women
had been writing for centuries I saw
that women can write like women and they
can write about different things than
men why not duh it took me years really
to climb on board so she always had kind
of a conflicted she she was never a
bandwagon person you know jump on this
because it's trendy it was something
that she she engaged with uh you might
say existentially she she had to um she
she was trying to sort through how she
ought to approach her her
Craft um I do have a few things on here
but I'm not going to go through the
entire itinerary about the awards that
she won uh just just for novels she's
won four nebula two Hugo One World
fantasy and five Locust Awards um there
were there were a number of other awards
that that she's won at different points
she's won awards for young persons
literature she's won awards for um uh
scholarship she's won awards for for
children's literature I mentioned yeah
Young Person's literature for for poetry
so she's really done quite a lot and
she's had a lot of recognition and she
seems you know if you read her
interviews it never really went to her
head which is pretty remarkable you know
you have to have a pretty good head not
to allow that that level to to get to
you so before we go into the
philosophical themes um let's talk about
this this world or rather universe of
the hinish novels so it's all science
fiction and it takes place on different
worlds that have been brought in contact
with each other in these these novels um
what's really interesting about it is
there isn't um faster than light travel
in it so you have to deal with these
these immense distances
and that means that you can't do stuff
like like you know we do in our typical
Sci-Fi series whether we do it with you
know hyperdrive or FTL drives or
Stargates or anything like that which
you can pop anywhere any any anyone
anywhere or warp you know warp speed and
and Star Trek right if you take that out
of the picture and you start thinking
about what the implications of these
vast distances are and what effect that
would have on human beings and their
relationships with each other
um you realize that you have to think
about life in in a very different way so
the the people who are traveling they
don't just leave you know whatever pipsy
or you know W AA or wherever they happen
to be behind they leave that time behind
by the time that they're at their
destination Point um because of the time
dilation effect and the fact that
they've usually been in stasis you know
essentially hibernating that whole time
they may have outlived everybody that
they know and when they come back it's a
totally different world that they're
coming back to so you know living on a a
particular world to go off world is a
big step um for for all of these people
and you think about the sort of
commitments why would you do something
like that it might be to build a better
life for yourself as the case in some of
the stories it might be because there's
a question that you need answered uh
like in renan's world with the the
character who has no idea what she's
getting herself into and travels um that
way and comes back and 15 years has
passed um it might be because you're
committed to some sort of large
humanitarian ideal as we'll we'll talk
about so they they have this this light
um near light speed travel um and then
there's one other thing that equalizes
stuff a bit and she coins the term
anible have any of you heard this before
it shows up in a lot of other people
science fiction as well so an anible is
think about essentially it's a
communication device so a walkie-talkie
right and that can reach anywhere so you
you can't physically move your your body
or Goods or things like that across the
cosmos
instantaneously but information can can
travel
instantaneously so you know in our day
where where we have you know gigabytes
of of storage available not that big of
a deal um she's thinking you know more
in terms of like what would you actually
send them what what sort of information
would you transfer and who would you be
willing to transfer it to you know if it
goes to the wrong person you're not
going to be able to do anything about it
it take you 60 years to get there and by
then they've done whatever they're GNA
do right so you know you wouldn't be
transmitting how to build an atam bomb
or how to poison people or things like
that because you could easily get in the
wrong hands but you could you could do
all sorts of other things um you think
about it you could you could transfer
music or you could transfer novels or
you could transfer anything else all the
whole sum of human knowledge from one
place to another um that that adds a
different wrinkle to it so you can't
transfer people and you can't transfer
physical Goods easily Among the Stars
but you can transfer all these other
things now the other um part part of
this this universe that's that's really
important human beings in this narrative
world didn't develop on Earth they
developed on another planet called Hine
that's why it's the hinish uh cycle and
that was a planetary civilization that
ends up you know traveling through the
stars and colonizing a whole bunch of
Worlds eventually it's going to collapse
but before it collapses under its own
weight they managed to put human beings
here and here and here and here
including Earth and they've also done a
lot of genetic uh modification and
perhaps experimentation on on people so
they're not always turning out the same
um the human beings that are the
original same human stock like the ones
on Earth um might not be the same as the
people for instance in this book where
they they actually um don't have gender
the way that we do and we'll talk about
that in in just a bit so the the the
hind civilization collapses and then
when that happens all of these worlds
become isolated and they think they're
the place where Humanity originates and
they're what what are human beings so
there's there's some interesting
conflicts where um you like in um uh
which is it the uh planet of Exile the
two different groups of of human beings
um each of them call themselves the
human beings and they have another word
for the other
people uh one is Hils and one is uh
farbor the farbor yeah yeah and but
they're all human they're all descended
from the same stock so uh eventually the
the worlds start to travel again through
the the you know through the the Galaxy
and they form a league of all worlds and
so this is you know in in a certain way
it's sort of like the Federation in in
in Star Trek they've got certain rules
rules they have to follow Star Trek they
have the prime directive right you're
not supposed to mess with other people's
civilizations so you know um this could
be commercial this could be like you
know introducing new ideas they're very
serious about this with the league so in
in that that um uh book planet of Exile
the the farbor are really in in a bad
position because they can only have the
technology that the local people have
and so they're like you know you stupid
people don't even have the wheel we've
been waiting for you to develop the
wheel for generations and you know why
couldn't you come up with that bless you
you know um but that's that it's a rule
so that they don't screw up other
people's cultures and it's kind of an
interesting idea to play with there's
there's a there's a respect there that's
that's a difficult to live with so
there's this league and it eventually
incorporates 80 worlds um it lives by by
you know these these rules um there's
some opposition to it there's an Empire
that tries to oppose it the the far
Empire but they're they're absorbed
eventually but there is an
enemy and it's just hinted at in some of
the stories uh like in renan's World um
the people on that world have to pay a
tax to the league to support the far off
war against this enemy and nobody knows
who it is by the time that we get to um
which one was it
um by the time that we get to um the
city of Illusion that's right um they
know who the enemy is it's it's this
group called The Shing who possess um
telepathy and not only are possess it
but they're able to lie with it and um
so they come in and they they mimic
Earth people they they just take over
the whole league and and um uh that one
takes place on on Earth City of
Illusions takes place on Earth and and
you get to see the Shing there so
there's this period where you know the
league has collapsed now there's a new
sheriff in town eventually they they
lose they're off um the uh the um the
scene and a new league in effect begins
to grow but it's called the ecumen and
this this is a name that comes from um a
Greek
termon which um well it's it's it's what
gets used when we talk about ecumenicism
in church relations the church is the oo
many it's the household that everybody
else lives in but this is also a Greek
word that they used to describe the sort
of overarching Greek culture and Roman
culture later of of antiquity that we
all part of one big household you know
like when business people sometimes say
oh we're all one big family even though
they don't really mean it you know they
usually say this when they want you to
you know take a a pay cut or something
like that or cut your insurance um it's
that that idea only without the the bad
is attached and the ecumen is even more
like the league in certain ways um I've
I I've got some um interesting quotes
from this book that we're going to go
into but the
eimen um begins spreading out again and
by the time that the left-handed
darkness is set there's 83 worlds and
they're talking about incorporating this
84th world so that is the whole um
narrative sweep that's the universe that
that that this whole thing is set with
in this is a good point to like maybe
take a pause and any questions or
comments or anything like that I've been
talking at you for quite a while uh and
then we'll talk about some philosophical
themes
so yeah U were there any for the the
Shing
people what they have a particular
motive other than just like taking just
conquest yeah that's a good question
um so the way that Ursula K leuin wrote
the
Shing um through the main character's
eyes the Shing are as a culture
pathological
liars and so you can't there there's
like this this this problem of figuring
out um what in the stories that they
tell are are um real and and what's just
made up because the Shing themselves say
that the league never really had an
enemy that's just something that we made
up later on to to you know uh provide
you know a coherent narrative um I don't
think we we really get any sort of
reliable insight into why they did it um
so I don't I don't have a that's okay
yeah I mean we could say because they
could but that's not really an answer
either well why did why why did they do
that well they what they did have is the
ability to
infiltrate um and uh and take over and
so so they they did and they do have
this this uh sort of respect for life um
but it's worked out in a really weird
way in in in the book Ursula K Len she
she
writes uh somewhere that she did she
wasn't really happy with the way that
she uh worked out the shame they was
they weren't sufficiently
evil or she didn't get it across right
you know yeah any other questions or
comments or yeah I interviewed Ursula
lwin back in the 70s oh probably
after 70 somewhere
7576 77 somewhere in that time period
here in Milwaukee she was here for a
convention some kind I can't remember
okay I got to talk with her and I had
read you know um left headed darkness
and dispossessed and a few others by
then too so yeah I I was really
fascinated with
her um her philosophical approach to
things I didn't didn't really like I
don't like socialism and I don't like um
some of the things that she was it would
seem to be she was you know proposing um
but she was very um Pleasant very and
very open to talking about things I mean
it wasn't yeah it wasn't like you would
have a conflict with her or anything
she' just she'd be very interested in um
your opinions or your questions um or
challenges probably right anything I
mean she was very I liked her a lot well
that's really cool I just yeah i' I've
had a few friends who have interviewed
some some famous people and sometimes
you hear stories like that they're
wonderful and and then sometimes you
hear stories like well that person's
really a jerk you and the public Persona
is is very very different so it's very
nice to I mean I I I would have never
suspected that she'd be anything other
than that given all the the other
interviews but that's really that's uh
quite amazing one of the things I think
is great about her and this was what
you're saying earlier about her efforts
toward really you know um supporting
children she's got this big notice on on
her website and it says feel free to
write me but don't expect to reply
unless you happen to be under 10 and
then you know try to give back to you so
I just think it's you know it's pretty
maybe that's her hedging her bets you
know that that you know those of us who
are older just say you're 10 yeah we
only got so much time ahead you know if
she wants her Legacy live on get the 10
year olds and then yeah yeah I mean
Plato had something like that right with
the noble lie in the Republic um at a
certain point Socrates has told this
whole story about like oh we're gonna
have this ideal society and then he also
says oh by the way we're we're going to
have to get rid of everybody who's under
a certain age and it might have been 10
because uh we got to start over
I don't think she has those sort of
motives
but I don't think Plato did either but
well this is a good lead in then to to
the eimen because um that's one of the
themes I wanted to talk about in a
certain way the eimen are
um you could think of them as like a a
projection of what she would have lik to
have seen in the world you know um it's
it's a it's a regime it's a a society
but it works without
coercion and it does so um recognizing
that this is going to lead to certain
problems eventually both the league and
the eimen are these very technologically
advanced civilizations that are engaged
in exploration of the Galaxy and
expansion of of Humanity's range and
then reincorporating the cultures that
they encounter on these other
planets the uh the league has a rule we
talked about for the colonies if you're
going to um you know stay in any place
you have to you have to keep your
technology at the level of the people
there and then you know if they make
advances then you get to have better
stuff so for example in uh plet of Exile
um because some of the local inhabitants
use poisons with their their their
weapons the these uh uh these other
people are able to develop much better
poisons you know because now poisons are
opened up for that but no wheel veh
Vehicles because they don't have any
Wheels the Acumen um they offer the
other people the chance to as they say
join the rest of humanity and so this
this whole book it starts out as a story
about how uh guley I the the um
representative of the ecumen is there to
try to offer joining to to first one
country and then the other um it's going
to turn into a different kind of story
later but the way that he presents it to
them is look you've got all these these
things that you can gain by doing it um
you have to deal in this with the worlds
and their cultures as they are and allow
them to to continue so it raises a lot
of interesting um political questions
and cultural questions like you know
should we be paternalistic meaning do we
know better than other people and we
just offer them stuff and say this is
how you need to live from this point on
or do we live leave people to their own
devices knowing that that means there
some of them are kill each other and
enslave each other and treat each other
in ways that look very irrational do we
have a responsibility to use power or
not to use power these are all things
that have to be decided um and the
ecumen is one answer to it it's saying
we're going to let everybody do their
thing and when they get into conflict
with each other we'll try to mediate uh
the conflict and try to use it we'll try
to use reason rational persuasion rather
than just weapons to to make it work um
so there's some really great lines in
this book especially where he talks
about um what's going on with the ecumen
this this I and so um the first thing
that he says when the king is asking
well why would we bother joining you
guys he says material profit the
increase of knowledge the augmentation
of the and complexity and intensity of
the field of intelligent life uh the
enrichment of Harmony and the greater
glory of God curiosity Adventure the
life and um then he says I was not
speaking the tongue spoken by those who
rule men the Kings conquerors dictators
and Generals in that language there's no
answer to this question um and then the
king ask him well how big is this
Kingdom out nowhere this acument he says
well there's 83 habitable planets and
the King says um why should I have
anything to do with these nations and
monsters living out in the void and he
says
um here we go trade
is the key idea in ideas and techniques
communed by ansible in goods and
artifacts sent by man or unman ships um
the eimen is not a kingdom but a
coordinator a clearing house for trade
and knowledge without communication
between the worlds of men would be
halfhazard and trade very risky men's
lives are too short to cope with the
time jumps Between Worlds there's no
network and centrality no control no
continuity to work for they that's why
they become members of the ecumen we're
all men all of us all the worlds of of
men and so that's one answer to the the
the question you know why would somebody
want to join for the possibility of
being part of a larger Network you know
being part of a
system um he also talks
about what happens you know when the
Acumen when conflicts happen he's asked
by another this is in another country he
says um what do you mean it doesn't
enforce its laws and so I says it
doesn't have any member states follow
their own laws when they Clash the
Acumen mediates attempts to make a legal
or ethical adjustment or collation or
Choice U and then he says if the ecumen
is an experiment in the super organic
does eventually fail it will have to
become a peacekeeping Force develop its
own police uh and so on but at this
point there isn't any need it's actually
working in the story up until this point
people are recognizing this is a more
rational way to do things and so you
know if we think about how how do we
deal with um the conflicts that we
experience in to Nations and cultures um
this is what Ursula Kaya green is
putting forth as as kind of an idea is
is it a
socialism um it could be if like one of
the member worlds is a socialist World
well then they get to be socialist right
uh she was she's actually more of an
anarchist I don't I don't know that she
was back then um but she she certainly
is now
and the ecumen would be a a kind of
um you know it's sort of like the United
Nations without the things that people
don't like about the United Nations you
might say right um it's also hard to see
how it would it would work without
eventually becoming something like a
police force yeah um yeah but it's you
know that's that's one of the things the
other thing that I thought was really
interesting in this book and this is a a
realization that I has
eventually um is that uh he
says alone I cannot change your world
but I can be changed by it alone I must
listen as well as speak alone the
relationship I finally make if I make
one is not impersonal and not only
political it is individual it is
personal it is both more and less than
political not we and they not I and it
but I and th
not political not pragmatic but mystical
in a certain sense the eimen is not a
body politic but a body Mystic it
considers Beginnings to be extremely
important and then he goes on so that's
why they only send one representative
who you know most people would be like
wow we're not interested in what you
have to this pedal crazy outworlder and
in this case actually pervert uh they
they consider him to be a pervert for
reasons that we'll we'll talk about um
but it's it's it's really interesting to
to consider this um this is a maybe a
utopian
dream but it's not a Utopia of this the
sort that we get from like Plato or
Thomas Moore or people like that um so
it's it's a good question what's what's
really going on here uh with that and
that's so that's one major philosophical
theme and this kind of feeds into the
second one which is the fact that leguen
identifies as a Dost and because of that
as an
anarchist um she actually did produce
recently I mean in the last several
decades a translation of the daed Jin um
she you know she saw it as a kid her dad
had had a copy and um she decided she
she wanted to actually write her own
translation so she she did and in in a
interview in the Paris review she said
something kind of interesting about um
dosm and about Buddhism she said I think
I have uh well I can't call it a
religious temperament because the
trouble is the word religion I'm
profoundly interested in both dosm and
Buddhism and they've given me a lot dosm
is just part of the structure of My Mind
by now and Buddhism is intensely
interesting to me but if you don't call
it a religious cast of mind then you
have to call it something spiritual and
that's woo woo and wishy-washy very you
know matter of fact I think there are
these big issues that religion tries to
deal with and I'm quite interested in
that that's the sort of meat there I
think so she said dosm gave me a handle
on how to look at life and how to lead
it when I was an adolescent hunting for
ways to make sense of the world without
going off into the god business and
returning to Lau throughout the years
I've always found him offering what I
want to what I want or need to learn my
translation or version or whatever it is
of the da of Jing is a byproduct of that
long and happy Association and she says
my knowledge of Buddhism is much
scantier and more recent um so it's
really dosm that's that's sort of the
show and there's there's references to
that I mean left hand of darkness is
coming from the the yinyang symbol um
you know the left hand of darkness is
light and and so on like that and so
there's a lot of themes that she's
taking from dosm that show up in her
writing some of these have to do with
like the notion of
balance and um you know the metaphor of
water and and things wearing each other
down the importance of the
environment um but but another thing
that's really key I think to
dosm is this there's this saying that
the da that you can speak of is not the
da so whenever you're like giving a
definition of something there's always
something that's escaping it um and I
think that's part of what is going on
with with her use of dosm the other
thing is dosm um I mean she she talks
about anarchists like
kotkin and other thinkers uh that we're
into sort of nonviolent
anarchism
um but I think she's also taking a lot
of that from dosm because the ideal for
dosm that you see in in the da of Jing
is that you don't want things to get too
big you want things to be you know able
to handle themselves in an organic
spontaneous way you don't want to be
imposing order from above um the way
that say a political system would do so
you know there there's anarchism in the
sense sense of like a
doctrinaire political
philosophy uh and there are people like
that out there right I mean there's
there's even I think if I remember right
an anarchist party I don't think they
they get anything done uh understandable
so right but um then there's anarchism
in the sense of like a kind of a
distrust of of power structures and and
what they do to human beings whether
they be run in a capitalistic way or
whether it's you know
democracy or whether it's a uh a
Communist Regime or a fascist regime you
know all of these have one thing in
common which is they boss people around
a lot and you know divide people up into
to different types of halves and Have
Nots and and and and they they restrict
um would be relations where people can
recognize each other as human beings um
and and so she's she's very committed to
that um she said something interesting
recently in an interview in motherboard
um reviewing this guy Murray uh
bookchin's book the next Revolution
which I Haven I haven't read so I I
don't know anything about it just had to
take her word for it here's what she
said that I think is really
interesting a lot of people are seeking
consistent constructive thinking on
which to base actions which is a
frustrating search theoretical
approaches that seem promising turn out
like the libertarian party to be anran
in in drag immediate and effective
solutions to a problem turn out like the
Occupy Movement to lack structure and
stamina for the long run so she's you
know targeting both left and and right
young people people this Society
blatantly short changes and betrays are
looking for intelligent realistic
long-term thinking not another ranting
ideology but a practical working
hypothesis a methodology of how to
regain control of where we're going
achieving that control will require a
revolution as powerful as deeply
affecting society as a whole as the
force it wants to harness and you know
if you look at our our current um very
interesting uh election cycle that we're
going through right now um I think
there's a lot of that that going on
there's a lot of people saying what's
the solution is it one of these two
candidates that somehow the parties have
have managed to settle on um is it some
Darkhorse candidate is it you know
voting libertarian is it voting green uh
even though that you know carries the
risk of being called uh a spoiler and
you know there's a lot going on and
there there are no easy clear answers to
this and young people are you know you
guys are in a very unenviable position
uh because the stakes are higher for you
than they are for the rest of us if
things go south um we're stuck with them
for maybe another 30 40 years you guys
are stuck with them for much longer and
the task of fixing things gets tougher
and tougher and she goes on and she says
um in this this this bit that she wrote
and
motherboard what all political and
social thinking has finally been forced
to face is of course the irreversible
degradation of the environment by
unrestrained industrial capitalism the
enormous fact of which science has been
trying for 50 years to convince us while
technology provided us greater
distractions from it every benefit
industrialism and capitalism have
brought us every wonderful advance and
knowledge and health and communication
and Comfort cast the same fatal Shadow
uh as as all we have taken from the
earth and taken with ever increasing
speed and greed and we now return little
but what is sterile or poison and this
is a really pressing issue we talked
about this a bit with with Frank Herbert
this notion of ecology you know there's
there's a mentality that looks at the
world the way that Aristotle did for
example he thought that everything was
more or less constant you can't destroy
the planet or you know wipe out species
or anything like that we know he's
totally wrong about that you know it's
possible for us to poison our water
supply we're fortunate that we live you
know in the Great Lakes area so we've
got these great reservoirs but we can
screw that up you know um and there's
all sorts of other issues and we're you
know if we look at our political um
landscape there's not a lot of people
who are tackling these things uh and
thinking you know 20 years down the line
they're thinking an election cycle four
years down the line um so she's you know
she's really on something and this is
what her novels are touching on um how
do we how do we you know do anything
about that she doesn't have the solution
I think um which is unfortunate but that
is you know I think that's where you can
see her anarchism she wouldn't she she's
not saying trust this group or trust
this group or trust this group she's ad
she's
advocating you know be critical um you
know you you decide where you want to
place your Vote or place your time or
your your energy and so this leads into
the Third thir philosophical theme that
um it's hard for me to articulate well
um and maybe some of you have a better
way of of talking about this one of the
things I see in her work is an intense
focus on the importance of the
particular the concrete the individual
human being and not in an
individualistic way we're like you know
we're all atomized individuals it's more
individuals in relations with each other
and with the world that they live in
maybe with their toothbrush if we want
to take a kind of silly example but you
know somebody a toothbrush is a pretty
trivial thing but you can get attached
to your toothbrush especially if you're
you only have one toothbrush you can't
go get another one at the store that
toothbrush can mean a lot to you and
somebody can say it's just a toothbrush
it's very trivial but it has a weight it
has a a meaning to it and so she um is
is is really excellent with this sort of
thing
in in and she doesn't spend a lot of
time like going into intricate
descriptions of and I picked a
toothbrush but that I don't think she
ever talks about a toothbrush um in this
book there's a sled that they have and
it's got all their food in it because
they have to do this like 800 mile Trek
across glacial ice to get from one place
to another place and they've only got
enough food to carry them through for a
while and that sled becomes in effect
their their you know part of major part
of their world it's keeping them alive
she doesn't describe it in great detail
but she doesn't have to um and she does
this with lots of other things as well
she's very good at focusing on common
human themes that we all have to live
out or or miss out on um so birth and
death you know there's a lot of that
going on childhood and the the
experience of Parenthood what is it like
to have kids kids um those of you who
have kids know that it's a you know very
mixed bag um you know sometimes it's
wonderful sometimes it's harrowing you
know sometimes you feel like you know
pulling your hair out because you can't
get them to see what they want to see
you know um conflict and competition
with each other that's often totally
confusing to us you know we get in
rivalries with other people and we can't
figure out why the hell we got into that
fight but we're still not going to back
down um loss and loneliness she's very
good at talking about that and and
having her characters think about those
sorts of things um the beauties of uh
and and appreciations that we have for
things that we experience frustrations
and joys of learning difficult decisions
that we have to make all of these things
matter even if they seem trivial or even
if they seem arbitrary they all matter
to her characters and it's not because
they're
small-minded it's because they realize
that the small things do do in fact
matter that even if you're a little
person you're not at the top of the you
know political food chain you're not the
one that they write history about you
matter too for for Ursula K Len's
stories at least um at the same time
she's also very tuned to how how humans
can be horrible to each other and can
justify all sorts of things and these
these go kind of go hand inand you know
um
so one of the things that I thought kind
of illustrates this is the way in which
this book in particular turns from being
a story about um how this guy I who is
the representative of the Acumen is is
trying to get the political leaders to
see that it's a good thing to join the
Acumen it goes from all of his
frustrations and his experiences on this
planet where um he's the only male uh
because there aren't any people who are
actually male per se there um goes from
from that to being a story about a
friendship that develops with this this
other character who is invested in in
the Acumen and all that but he's he's
one of the natives there and um the
depth of the Friendship it's solidified
in part by this travel across the ice
but also in their sharing with each
other um and it's really quite beautiful
and so I started thinking about where
should we you know turn for thinking
about this philosophically and I've got
some some thinkers who who do talk about
the the importance of the the um
concrete the fact that um one's
friendship with another person might not
be you know the ultimate buddy story but
it it matters it's real uh and I think a
lot of times people lose sight of that
and it's we live in a culture ourselves
where it's very easy to lose sight of
that sort of thing because we have that
you know fear that things are not going
to be as as wonderful as they could be
um um instead of like actually looking
at things the way they are and seeing
the goodness in them as they are we want
them to be something something different
than they than they are um so I I don't
know what to call that you know yeah I
think or I was thinking along because
you mentioned Daoism so there's like the
assertive and the passive and I think
it's the passive way to make the
argument for
humanitarianism okay that you're arguing
for the worth of a person just by
showing
them by by showing them did you say Yeah
by showing their life okay yeah
similarly to what she was saying I was
thinking about an anarchist terms of
rejecting all hierarchy of yeah you like
there's no type of relationship or thing
that could be worth something that is
worth more than something else because
she's rejecting that certain people
would be more important or that the
society you know like all the leaders
are more important than these two random
people who are friends if that makes
sense yeah like focusing on
individualism showing their worth in a
mundane way so like they don't need to
be um somehow the most important thing
that's happening in the way we
conceptualize yeah although there there
there will be moments where you do have
to like decide go this way save this
person or save that person um but there
you're right there's no like
pre-arranged more like like an evolution
like the punctuated equilibrium like
they can subside and be not that
important and and suddenly assume
importance right yeah yeah yeah go ahead
um what you're talking about and her
focus on the individual and the concrete
and so it's just good storytelling I
mean I yeah I was a reporter for many
many years and you always wanted to have
an anecdote uh an example a specific
thing to back up if you had a a bigger
message you wanted to tell it through an
individual's story uh and and I think
think the best storytellers of any kind
have always done that um and she
certainly is one highlighted is another
you can you could get these other
broader themes in there but they're
always told through the individual if
otherwise it gets it's like a
generalization and you can't get any
interest into that you know you can't
and you got to be able to do it well
because you don't want to sometimes an
individual just ends up being kind of
like we call it a stock character right
you're like yeah I've already heard that
story before but these you're right
these are these are uh individuated
stories we we might
say
um yeah she succeeds in making us care
about you know people who we otherwise
might just say who cares about that
person I mean I her whole thing with the
dispossessed I believe it was where the
idea was to have this everybody's
equal but you know it turns out that
they they've kind of missed the boat
because they've ignored individual needs
and
individual uh creativity and all of that
by trying to make everybody the same and
I think she does a really good job of
pointing out why that doesn't work I
mean what are the problems with that you
know another one that comes to mind too
is so in the lath of Heaven are you guys
I'm not GNA I won't assume that
everybody's familiar with it but unless
unless you guys are everybody okay so
really short synopsis this guy has
dreams and his dreams can manipulate
reality and he's going to a psychiatrist
I think maybe a psychologist because he
um realizes that his dreams are changing
reality and he's the only person who
grasps that A change is taking place so
it's driving him nuts and his his uh I
guess we'll just say therapist because I
don't know what what what she was um at
first thinks well he is nuts because
that's a crazy thing to think right but
then she gets in on the um the the uh
the secret and she realizes that she can
like put him under hypnosis and then
give him uh suggestions about what he
should dream so what would you do in a
situation like that well make the world
a better place right we eliminate
poverty or eliminate war or and by the
time that she's done it starts to get
further and further out of control
because she hasn't like changed this
thing and then there's some unforeseen
consequences right and by the time that
she's done everybody has gray skin um I
don't really remember too much else
about I that was that's not what I
reread for this but um there's there's a
few other it's like they're trying to
make everybody totally equal it it just
totally eliminates everything
interesting about about human beings and
uh I don't you
know I don't there's a movie version of
it I think there's two movie versions
because sci-fi did a movie version as
well and I don't remember exactly if
they follow it all the way out to the
end but it's a kind of despairing I
think for all ear was in the first
version the one that was in 79 the PBS
version yeah okay very good yeah I
remember the Sci-Fi version had somebody
who like making a comeback by doing it
but I don't remember who off hand I
remember seeing it on the TV but um but
it illustrates that same idea of well we
Tinker around because we're not happy
with legitimately not happy with the
fact that we like you know we were
terrible to each other and
and uh there's all sorts of you know
inequities and and bad things going on
and then we end up stripping the good
away as well yeah there's always
unintended consequences which is what I
think she did a very good job of of
showing you know no matter how much
Social Engineering you think you're
going to do you're always going to screw
up because you won't know what the
unattended consequences are yeah go
ahead oh I do think that there's kind of
a comparing and a contrasting between
between social engineering where you're
going in and you're like making a change
like you're the therapist just like
wishing something like poverty is gone
kind Thing versus social change that
happens by rational argumentation like
in the left hand of darkness and through
people slowly coming to things and
willingly coming to things not being
forced into it because even if you're
changing the whole reality and so
consent gets kind of murky people
certainly didn't actively consent to
things being changed they didn't ever
agree with they just kind of were and so
it's more of a parable about crude
social engineering than never try and do
anything but like do anything through
much more subtle or like um not covert
subtle but subtle like small in in good
size doses they use a word for that
today called nudging um and there's an
interesting debate about um whether
you're more respecting the people people
that you're nudging than if you were
bringing like uh clear pressure to bear
on them and the nudging would be things
like you know you make the soda machine
harder to get to so that people don't
don't drink as much soda that or you
know instead of saying when nobody gets
to smoke you well you make the smokers
go outside and you know make the the
ashtrays kind of small so it's hard to
get them in there right now are you how
how much are you being you're not being
coer so the the question is well are you
are now you you know that this stuff
actually works so if you know that you
can you're not pushing people's buttons
quite so obviously is when you bring
coercion but you're just you know you're
kind of pushing them a little bit are
you are you still are you treating them
in a paternalistic way then or are you
treating them in a more um you know in a
more autonomous way you're letting them
make their decisions there's a lot of
debate about about this heard of like
two different types of n like two
different examples or they didn't
present it this way but like I kind of
segregated n like hearing about nudges
into two different things that there
were the ones that you're talking about
which are almost kind of like passive
aggressive instead of you know like in
they are kind of coercive because you
make your go stand outside in the cold
that's a harm that could hurt um but
then there were the ones that were just
like a text reminder like on a video
game where people are saying terrible
things to each other in the chat it
would just be like a reminder at the top
of the screen your team works better
when you all get along oh interesting or
like in Ireland I know I think it was
Ireland
put images of blackened lungs on the
cigarette packages oh that's not subtle
at all no that's that's like in the
middle it wasn't harder to buy it it
wasn't more expensive it just when you
bought it that's the image but is that
psychological harm in kind of a way
that's coercive or is it or
manipulative information information
right that I put like in my in my like
Spectrum that's right in the center
where I don't know where to quite place
it because like on I was trying to say
like one seems to be the rational
discourse so like it's above the board
you know you're being talked to and on
the other side it's like making the soda
machine hard to get to you might not
even realize and then so it is kind of
that's why it works right by the way you
can you can go back to when uh when was
it back in the 60s when in advertising
they actually had the
sub
messages you didn't consciously see the
image it was buried in there so fast
that your mind picked it up yeah like
being hacked kind of like your brain
brain hacked versus being addressed and
that was a standard advertising practice
for a while in the movie theaters right
I
think they would adver like soda things
and there St up did that for a while and
then people all of a sudden would race
out and you know that's one of the
things Disney got in trouble forne for
what how did that happen they were
um was it was it some of the old when
they first released VHS tapes um oh
people would freeze it and find them
well they'd have things in there that
they had embedded into the VHS tapes
that were connected to um sort of like
consumer you know oh interesting
purchase patterns yeah well I mean all
this goes to like that question the
ecumen is sort of a representative of
rational above the board get full
consent but then the problem with that
is you know sometimes it takes
generations to get full consent
meanwhile these people are killing each
other and so she doesn't have an answer
but she's don't full consent I mean
sometimes I mean if you're a for-profit
motive you're going to use whatever the
technology you can invent no law says I
can't do this I don't pretend about
ethics I'm here to make a buck yeah so
you do these things and and that's a
certain type of manipulation or social
engineering but it's for your own
personal gain you know but then we you
know look on the sort of the not for
profit side and then we concern
ourselves about big organizations
manipulating us but we're more concerned
sometimes about that than we are the
for-profit people that are doing stuff
we haven't even discovered yet yeah well
and and too like the um the things that
are in a weird situation like the big
internet companies there's there's a
debate about should they be considered
something like public utilities right or
or are they essentially for-profit
corporations because you know Facebook
every I mean anytime they do an over
change people go nuts I can't believe
you headed this button you know or took
away that button but all the little
things like you know that we all the
data stuff that we're consenting to give
them
there what was your thing with Google
she she she out of um out of the author
SK because digital RS yeah because her
view was that um uh it was it was
impacting copyright and copyright is the
only real um safe guard against you know
if you're it's tough as an author anyway
uh or anybody who's developing
intellectual
property um it's tough to make a living
and it makes it even tougher when Google
can just take everything for free I mean
I'm in a situation kind of like that
myself with with YouTube I generate tons
and tons of content and who knows how
much you know Revenue I've generated in
advertising even just just the ones that
I don't have any advertising on but it's
on the side for for Google as as a
result you know
um and you know there's many other
people in that situation she was she was
really upset about Google Books because
Google Books was digitizing all this
stuff she wasn't the only one I mean
there were authors all over the world
who are suing yeah there's a good um
documentary on that oh yeah I think it's
called Google world or something like
that and um it it talks about all the
people around the around around the
world from Japan England France when
they started finding out what Google was
doing because Google kept it hidden for
quite a while oh really oh yes this this
goes into that this was a very uh secret
project for quite a long time the Google
Books thing well then you have the other
side of it if I don't know how how many
of you have Kindles or Nooks yeah
libraries now if if lary buys a hard
copy book they can loan it out as many
times they want but if they get a digal
book they now have a limit on how many
times it can be checked out oh
interesting I didn't know and it has to
do with copyright and authors but it
limits what they can do yeah because
they can't loan it out indefinitely like
you can a hard copy book maybe they have
to relicense it and they have to pay
there's a whole yeah maybe they're
thinking like in L would eventually have
to Rey A Book Like it get beat up and
then 10 years later you'd buy a new one
but you never need to buy buy new but
the number the number of digital copies
they're allowed to use is much less than
we take to wear our book that's
interesting you have time have wait yeah
I mean because libraries are going
digital so much you know um my favorite
thing the ones that disappear what's up
my favorite thing is the ones that that
when you download an ebook and it
disappears after a certain amount of
time it's like Mission you know
like the that you were quoting her um
how many years ago was that that which
one the well there was one um I forget
the um the reference you gave to where
it came from well here's my question
yeah I
mean has she um is there more recent
like in the last year interview with her
oh yeah that she's talked about uh any
progression has she progressed in terms
of her message her exploration between
her different books that she's
culminated in boy that wild girls is
just really it I mean or not oh I mean
just to pick a recent one of the popup
you mean it like artistically well or
just to express what she's been trying
to do I mean if she's balancing dosm and
other things I don't I don't think or
just a Storyteller just say these came
to my mind and so I've written another
one it's kind of like the others but I'm
not really
progressing I I don't think she one of
her recent books she said is is uh one
of her favorite books the linia which is
2009 in one of the interviews that I saw
um and I remember this was one of the
other ones um but I don't I haven't seen
anything where she said something like
well um I mean I've seen some things
where she
said uh in decades past that that her
stuff she thought had gotten better by
like um thinking through feminism for
example um but that's like decades ago
you know that's not any any recent new
development I but I I didn't like Co
well part of it it goes back you were
reading a list out of the out of the
book there about yeah entering new
worlds or something you are you doing it
for enjoyment or profit or domination or
whatever so yes I would throw that
question back to her every every her I
think she's a very just say you know I
mean you've been doing this you're in
your 80s you've been doing it for you
know 60 years or something you know have
you know what have you why are you doing
this other than entertainment I mean so
what have you found I mean your dad was
an anthropologist yeah yeah you know
which is really a different thing than
storytelling but digging into learning
how people behave within their cultures
presuming
culturist you know and so how does that
fit in with what she's trying to do here
I guess other than maybe just I just do
these These are entertaining I'm not
trying to create any big progression or
any big diagnosis on where we're going
going on or prognosis or anything else
well each one is so there's two issues
there there's there's the issue of
whether she's writing things that are
essentially supposed to be
entertainments versus being like social
commentary or you know experimenting
with ideas and then there's a question
of whether there's a progression I think
the answer to the first is all of her
stuff definitely is like social
commentary but whether there's a
progression um from the early earlier
stuff to a more coherent message or like
I now I know that you know this is this
is bad I don't see something like that
in her Works um as we move towards the
newer stuff as a matter of fact um I
remember being a little disappointed
reading the new earthy stuff because I I
I felt some of it was a little preachy
um but a little preachy not like you
know some some authors R read them and
you're like wow this is really this is a
great book before and now this stuff is
is really just um they're trying to get
across this agenda or something like
that which I think maybe happens more as
you get older I think one of the things
and I'm G to weirdly connect this
probably in a stretch to the original
question yeah about mundane things yeah
and focusing in on those like like a
toothbrush or a sled or like you know
you can have a pebble you had as a kid
that you ascribe meaning and symbolism
and purpose to yeah and it's kind of
like how we I think that speaks how
people create meaning for themselves and
create symbolism and that's created in
these big things too not just in
toothbrushes but in conceptions of
society things we take for granted like
coercion and gender and um how politics
could work or violence and if it's
necessary and I think the point of her
books in some ways is to talk about how
we've created these things that we take
for granted and we're going to see what
would happen if we didn't and she's not
maybe she doesn't have an opinion of
that maybe she doesn't know is good or
not or is
coercion necessary or not but she's
going to explore it in a theoretical
framework to say hey we have these
things that we've created we've created
meaning we've created symbolism and
we're g to see what would happen if we
changed it promise weever run out of
that too like aun take a fundamental
part of life and just say switch that
try yeah so that's a good segue into the
the other theme that I was going to talk
about which is um this sort of like
experimenting with using fiction to
experiment and doing thought what would
things be like if this were different
now in this one it's it's it's it is
about gender it is about about sexuality
and so one of the things that she said
um and I think this I think this was in
that that um Paris review interview
which is from some years ago she said in
the 60s it became important to a lot of
us especially women and gays to try to
get a better idea of what exactly gender
consisted of him Tarzan me Jane no
longer seemed quite adequate the science
fiction mirror offered itself as a great
way to get a different angle on the
whole thing to me though it's not a
release or escape from our world my
world is all I have to make my stories
from my people people are the only
people I know but this is what you're
saying by making up worlds and peoples I
can recombine and play with what we have
and our I can ask what if it were like
this instead of like this what if nobody
had a fixed gender which is the case in
in this work where they um they go
essentially into heat every so often and
then they can either be male or female
they made and then they're they either
conceive or they're done with it and
they don't think about it the rest of
the month whereas the rest of us from
the PE from the perspective of the
people in this book we're all perverts
because uh some of us have male organs
and some of us have female organs and we
have them all the time and so it's it's
really quite an interesting thing and
you know the most interesting thing
about that in this book is she's doing
it with a male character she's writing
as a female writer about a male
character trying to figure out what his
masculinity really means in relation to
these people who are neither masculine
nor feminine but kind of a amalgam of of
both um and she does a wonderful job at
it um but she goes on and she says what
what if marriages instead of two people
in one couple consisted of four people
and four homosexual and heterosexual
couples is do on the planet oh that's
really a complicated Arrangement right
um if nobody in a world had ever waged
War how would people in daily life in
that world differ from ours in in what
ways so it's not just about gender but
about other things by doing you know
what in philosophy we call thought
experiments but doing them in a
narrative framework she's able to try to
explore how how we might see things
differently and it probably you know I
think it probably was a lot more
pressing for women me to be doing that
in the 60s then for uh heterosexual men
um and then she also said in another
thing people seem to be people wherever
they are whatever they look like in the
left hand of Darkness I tried to
experiment to see if you took gender
away from people for most of the month
would they still be human that's an
interesting question if you took our
gender away would we still be human and
then her answer was yeah they did they
do but you only find that out by trying
to write believable characters
that somebody else could not not
yourself as the author because as the
author you probably always think your
characters are great or or or you have
the other thing where you think they're
terrible but you have somebody else read
it and say does this seem like plausible
to you and then if they say yeah then
maybe you've learned something in the
process and there you know including the
time period She was writing that book
there were feminists who were discussing
you the concept of getting rid of gender
in our society and they were advocating
for that and the way maybe a scientist
would say is this a good way to cure
cancer they might do some tests this
could be her tests of is it a good way
to fix Society sexism to eliminate
gender you know what I mean to think
what if we could change this what would
happen and as an experiment like running
a test like will that help will that fix
that problem yeah I mean it's
interesting too because the people on
this planet um are just as
ethnocentric in in their own way as
anybody else they like I said they'd all
think we're we're complet Ely perverts
because we have fixed gender you know
all of our life so so they're kind of
conservative even though yeah yeah well
they're very conservative in this in
this book U there's there's several
different uh um countries and each of
them has their own this is the way that
you do things uh kind of thing um so
that's that's that's an interesting
theme um do do we want to talk about the
those who walk away from alalas or want
to do General discussion for the time
that we have left it's it's up to you
guys um I don't know who's who's ever
encountered it before it's kind of an
interesting thought
experiment it's it's a little might
leave you a little raw if we end on
it so it's pretty
rough it's up to
you I familiar with it okay do you want
to should we do it or not I'm up for it
okay
so um this is something that she said
about before I try to paraphrase she
said teachers in all kinds of field
literature philosophy sociology
economics use it as a discussion starter
it poses a frightening moral question
which William James and doeski both
asked and which is directly relevant to
our society and offers no direct
resolution this makes some students so
angry and unhappy and unsatisfied that
they want to complain about it and then
other students want to explain it to
them which is usually ineffective um so
here's there's a place called omalos
andos is a really great place to live
you know Wonderful um you know
architecture and the society is set up
well people don't get sick the way they
do it in our country we can come up with
all sorts of things and I don't remember
all of the uh stuff that she says so I'm
just going to roughly paraphrase here
but imagine a great place to live now
everybody in
when they are at a certain age I think
it's 16 or so they're brought down into
this this uh essentially a dungeon
beneath beneath a uh one of the main
buildings and they see a cell and what
they find in that cell is a child who is
chained up there and will never be able
to to escape and this child is um in
pain
constantly and they're lonely they are
um in many ways uh not just
disadvantaged but disabled they uh they
can't understand their circumstances if
you took them out of the cell they
wouldn't be any happier because they
wouldn't know what what to do with
themselves but all of these people are
told it she takes many more pages to do
this but all these people are told the
happiness of our society depends on the
suffering of this one child it's just
one kid just one there always has to be
one though but I mean look at the whole
society look how big it is how
harmonious how many people are here you
know everybody's living well but here's
the thing if you're going to stay here
you have to be okay with this you can't
just you know like change your mind
later on you must decide now and so it's
called those who walk away from omus
because most of them say okay from a
utilitarian perspective you know the the
suffering of the one is great greatly
outweighed by the the benefits to the
many this is a no-brainer um I'm I'm
okay with it and some people are
troubled but they come up with some sort
of reasoning to get by and others say I
can't I can't do this I can't be part of
this and they walk away from omus and so
the question is well what would you do
and why would you do it and you know do
you have if you're one of the people who
says I wouldn't ever go along with that
sort of thing um are you better than the
other people who who stayed there or or
not these are sort of the questions that
it provokes and you can use it in a lot
of different ways what what do you get I
mean some of you have read it before
Doctor Who did an episode very much
based on with the whale wh I was just
for the
Beast the Beast the Beast below the
Beast below is it like in constant
pain SE whale who's in constant pain yes
providing energy for it's the ship it's
it's it's
London oh it's Great Britain on the back
of those the world it they escaped and
they and it broke apart into pieces and
this but is it like a better London at
least
or it's not really apocalyptic space
limited resources I dysfunctional
Society is it possible to leave is a dis
space fling through space there's no
place to go there like the the ruler of
the society and she like she like has
Amnesia or something but every like so
many years she has to redecide to either
like kill everyone or keep torturing the
whale and the whale is like conscious
it's not just like a whale a space whale
it's the last of its kind oh wow that
every time has and she's the only one
who's aware of it and it's the the queen
it's the queen okay yeah yeah that's a
somewhat different thought experiment
because it's just her side right the
other people don't have
any everybody knows about it but they
end up they choose to have
amnesia or wow or or decide that they
don't they want to protest so like you
vote every it's basically the same
concept and of course comes out with an
alternative what's the alternative
actually it's not
it's compion comes up with it finds out
that the whale actually wants to help
and if they would stop torturing it it
would help any way oh that's that's
good everybody wins let it alone that
the whale the the the space whale
is
um selfless yeah and will help
especially because there are children
yeah yes and it cares about the children
and they don't have to torture it for it
to support the city well that that's a
way out of the Dilemma it's fortunate
they could write that in there
CU children yeah there's nothing like
that in in this one because the kid you
know the kid has no idea why he's
suffering yeah but you know yeah I'm I'm
one of those ones to say if every if you
can sacrifice one individual for every
other one no one else's life has any
value everyone every individual life has
value you cannot you cannot force one to
sacrifice for the others if you do you
everyone loses value so that seems to me
a very easy thing to solve yeah if you
if your result is supposedly going to be
chaos or a place less than beautiful
then um you go there because it probably
won't be that
way it's only somebody's determination
that this place is going to be beautiful
because you're torturing one individual
yeah I mean they'd all know about it all
the time you know I suppose they could
like expunge it from their their memory
she does doesn't go into any of that
that sort of stuff the thought
experiment um I'm focusing on how tough
it would be to make the decision at 16 I
can't I can't even think what I would
would probably feel the pressure of my
family like well well everyone else has
has been okay with this yeah why why are
you not okay with it you know you're
going have to leave the family you have
to leave your home you're have to leave
this place as a 16-year-old I don't know
if I could make the decision as as a
much older person now I I agree
torturing one person for for the benefit
of other people is not acceptable and I
think when you make like if you amplify
that from this very like small like over
this one city and one person what that
is is saying that there could be a class
of people that you co and manipulate for
the betterment of your your class of
people and that that could be in any
slavery or well yeah slavery or just any
any sort of Oppression where you're sort
of manipulating you're saying it works
out for the best yeah oh and and there's
a couple things going on there one of
sort of explaining a way that oh there's
no other way to do it just saying oh
there's no other way we can fix it this
is the way that it is you either choose
it or or all Society crumbles you have
to choose like either we torture
everyone or like that's kind of like a
lie you're telling yourselves in some
way like to get away from it and even if
it was true the sort of like I kind of
agree with her on the cor coion and
hierarchy being sort of evils of
humanity like you can't view one person
is not will like doesn't deserve the
right to have sort of humanity and
freedom of like choice in some way what
about really terrible people you know
who to Define they're terrible oh well I
mean so for for us like aens there's
some things that are clearly terrible
you're going around just killing people
for the sake of you know sadism or
something like that now and she I don't
think she'd go through a moral
relativist you know well who's de say or
anything like that so but then then you
know those are easy to say well then we
got to lock them off or something like
that but then we get this whole like
Borderland of what do you do with the
Abus of husband um who because his idea
of masculinity is tied up with um
treating his spouse poorly and then if
she you know resents it uh beating her
up um I don't know maybe you should
resist him maybe maybe you should tell
him that that he doesn't get to I'm not
saying no resistance I'm saying like
there's a definite difference
between I actually think the Abus ofm is
more analogous with the society abusing
the individual child because not then
the child themselves because they're the
one who has the power in the situation
and they're rational oh we should be
okay with the husband abusing someone
because it's from his masculinity or the
society is okay with torching a kid
because they've explained it away to
themselves but your
reasoning however much it makes sense
all along the way doesn't
justify what you're doing in yet but at
the same time both individuals in that
theoretical story are trapped within
their larger society we use of husband
had a childhood and and gained his
perspective and his negative behavior
and so not that he's the same level of
level of victim if that's even a thing
you can talk about but um that's where
they talk about restorative justice and
that you yeah you maybe get the the
woman out of that situation you support
her but you would try to psychologically
heal the other individual as much as
possible yeah I mean that's tough to do
because you can only you can only do
that like in in stages and and with
getting him actually to buy into it and
sometimes it takes so much resources
this is actually one of my problems with
with restorative justice which I I used
to do a lot of work on is um I I get the
general idea behind it and when it works
it works really when it does work it
works really well but it also there
there is a victim's rights not not just
argument but sentiment against it
because they're like wait a second what
about us you know uh we didn't create
this situation that guy did it and and
um sometimes you when your resources are
limited and they usually are in criminal
justice situations or volunteer
situations you got to decide where
you're going to allocate those those
resources and and the those are the sort
of problems that she worries about I
think quite a bit is how do we allocate
these scarce resources one of the things
I like about science fiction and I did
from the very beginning and I think two
good examples are both Doctor Who and
Star Trek is they present alternative
Solutions solutions that seem nobody
thinks about you know oh you're stuck
you're actually stuck you're going to
die you're going to die you know this is
good and all of a sudden there's a
different there's a different like
looking at it from a completely
different perspective allows you to find
another solution yeah and that is from
from what I could see from the very
start science fiction has been able to
do that some science fiction has you
know I
think so the Star Trek universe you're
right is full of that sort of
stuff I don't think Star Wars
is Star Wars is just more
straightforward Star Wars it's more like
The Westerns of space
yeah
um yeah I really have to think about
that I'm wondering if when we talk about
ecology and we talk about husbands in
the Star Trek Doctor Who Universe
there's no
religion well what with the Federation
there's the Federation there's no
religion religion there are
religions people in there are religious
like in other civilizations but not
within oh there's no there's no one for
the whole there in other civilizations
there are religions but um and some some
of the people practice something they
rituals some do but not within Earth
yeah
no there's a discussion there's a
discussion about it in next Generation
with Bard and he talks about one of the
things that makes the universe different
is they got rid of religion they made
the Earth different and what was the
thing on vo talks about there's a this
the like first mate whatever it's called
he's um they don't ever specify a tribe
but he's a Native American and he
practices his religion oh chot yeah chot
yeah yeah um yeah I think I mean start I
think is okay with religions that would
be ethnic religions they're not you know
we make a distinction sometimes in
religious studies between ethnic
religions where somebody's born into it
and you're not going to share it with
Outsiders usually uh and then Universal
religions so like Christianity Islam
Buddhism those are Universal Rel Rel
yeah I was going with that was what you
get into with
ecology is and we have people today um
moris udol was the first one that came
to mind mind who because of their
religious perspective yeah had no
trouble with destroying the Earth
because the end times is coming oh
there's that yeah yeah there's that and
then there's also the subdued conquer
subdued conquer and then in the domestic
violence realm you run
into uh pastors and religious leaders
who tell women that they have to stay
with the abuser because it's still death
to you part yeah or or that um you know
the Pauline line of you know why sub
their husb wives sub into their husbands
yeah I mean you got to do a lot of
selective reading to to weed out all the
other stuff you know uh which which
would say you know can't do that sort of
thing but but you know the Bible like
any other document is what what we call
a wax nose you can turn it you know
whatever way you want
to yeah so that's those are all good
points so in that story the story yeah
the the actual goal of their leaders is
to put the
this adolescent or pre this teenager and
make that make that decision and the
decision is that they want to keep
torturing the child no it's not an
option whether they keep torturing the
child it's the child is going to be
tortured but I mean that the the this
person that's being made to
choose they they're I'm assuming they
want them to be okay with it yeah that's
it accept it I would think
more interesting story be if someone's
okay with it that person gets kicked out
W hologram child and then you're like
all right you're out yeah that's that
yeah although I mean it's the the
society has been going on for
generations and this has been the the
price that they they have to pay so it's
kind of like the you know when I was in
basic training we we would have um there
was kind of two reactions other than
sheer Terror to the to the drill s
and one was um that I had was like boy
if I ever get Authority I'm not going to
act like these jerks because you know I
I don't like this and there are others
who like I don't like it either so I
can't wait until I get some Stripes so I
can do this to some other poor bastard
and make him suffer you know and I I
always had a hard time understanding
that um but there were quite a few guys
like that in there and I think that in
um I'm not sure exactly how that applies
to thealist story I think I lost my my
train of thought bit well not
really it's yeah it's it's again it's
that choice whether you're going to take
you know that guy's going to take his
revenge out or you're just going to say
I don't approve of this yeah and my
question would be this child that's in
there like you said he didn't really
have even if he was released his life
wouldn't be that much different yeah
that's that's one of the that's what I
was going to ask about what's what's the
situation with the child I mean is this
the child's I say stupid world like
Destiny but
um that works it wouldn't it wouldn't
be I I mean you have to get beyond the
horror of this and start looking at at
the you know something from a higher
level
here if it would be no different you
know if it doesn't even I don't know
what's the level of Consciousness and
that kind of thing so those are the
questions I would kind of Imagine
imagine a kid with like an IQ of like 70
or so and they there's nothing they can
do because they've been so damaged I
think that and again I'm paraphrasing
it's been a while since I looked at the
the story itself because I haven't
taught it for for quite some is there
any other normal for this person is what
I no is kind of I mean I hav't read the
book but I don't I mean what I just from
what you were I only read planet of
Exile and I thought that was really
fascinating I saw so many themes in
there it just like fascinating to me and
that whole thing with that League really
bugged me because I thought you know
like you can't get Beyond this cuz I but
wheny pardon me you mean like the they
had to lower they have to keep primary
technology but then in the end when they
had when the bading Army came in and
they had the war and then the Hils the
higher know High Life whatever with the
fart they had to you know move in with
them because they were being completely
wiped out I don't know if there was I
don't remember was there any sort of
crossover on The Hil side saying maybe
we got to look at this way of living
that we could learned something from
these people um when when you're
speaking to her about that other things
with her it seems like she's got a very
integrative Consciousness that she's she
talks about the Arcane and the Magical
and the Mythic and the and then rational
then she goes into modern and postmodern
finally when you integrate all of that
that's kind of what I see as her
philosophy it's very intrical on there
and she she and all but all of these
levels have to be one has to meet
another to rise up I think I just about
the thing with the kid
part of the thing is that the kid isn't
naturally a level at 70 IQ IQ I assume
that it's the society putting him in a
cage for his entire life and sort of
torturing him has has somewhat put him
in that or him or her I don't know in
that position so I think and also if you
leave omes you don't actually stop the
kid from being tortured so the question
is more are you willing to be a part of
society that's willing to do something
like this or not whe not because you're
not actually going to save the child in
this scario you're not going to start
Revolution and break them out you're
just choosing is my allegiance here or
can I not be with a society that would
torture in it so this is about like a
moral code or something although it is
kind of like maybe a faith in that same
kind of slow very passive change because
when um I first read it in college in a
college class philosophy class and we
were we were talking about it first you
know because I tend to you know um
science major do things by a num I was
like well I mean this makes me feel
really bad but should I listen to that
maybe not look at the numbers look at
this person you know there's no hope but
then I was thinking about you know maybe
more of the activist causes I was more
dedicated to or my moral code but It
ultimately came down to yeah I walk away
and it doesn't make a difference I
recycle and it really doesn't make a big
difference I vote for maybe someone
who's slightly better than the other to
my mind and maybe it doesn't make a big
difference but um the more I can walk
away from the coercive and the negative
and the Heart even if I'm not really
changing everything with the water
metaphor and D I'm like one drop yeah
that for every person to walk away from
omal eventually maybe it would become it
be abandoned the whole city would be
abandoned there would be no new child to
replace the old you know there's another
thing too with that sort of line of
reasoning is we never we never really
know when we're doing what feels to us
like a meaningless though
well-intentioned gesture if it if it is
going to affect somebody and sometimes
we have the fortunate occurrence of
somebody coming up to us later on and
saying hey that may made a difference so
there there was a guy now this is not a
great example of this in certain
respects because I I blew up at this guy
and chewed him
out it was my first it was my first like
week teaching in in a Maximum Security
Prison and this guy and I was a real
hotthead back then and this I was
straight out of grad school and and this
guy um he was in a like a religion class
of some sort and and we were reading
some text he's like well my opinion is
and I was like nobody cares what your
opinion is you know that's not what
class is about you know that go back to
the dorms and and talk about that if you
want to just spout your opinion and he
shut up he was kind of ticked off and
then he didn't talk to me for like two
years and he came up to me and he said
you know um that was exactly what I
needed to hear at the time and it helped
me to like rethink what I was doing and
I was like well well it was really a
jerk thing for me to say to you and I I
did it the wrong way but I'm glad it
worked out for you well and then he and
I got to be friends um because because
he really had you know I saw a lot of
people engaging in Rehabilitation there
um and uh you know it's kind of a good
example not a good example of a well in
intentioned gesture I was just trying to
shut him down I was being a jerk but it
had a good effect and now imagine if I'd
like actually done good
stuff
respect that probably would yeah well we
should we should probably end because I
know they're going to close up here soon
so great discussion um thanks for all of
your you know comments and and attention
um very very nice